[Musique]
un concert de l'orchestré de la garde
républicaine au désert de red sa
chambourcy s'ils ont l'habitude de jouer
dans des salles de concert au théâtre ce
dimanche 26 juin les 65 musiciens ont
interprété leurs morceaux en plein air
des musiques inspirées du lieu au
répertoire beethoven puccini ou encore
bizet le dernier de bizet oui on bien
sûr très très connu une interprétation
comme ça avec le solo de flûte tout à
l'heure juste pronostics on a essayé de
se rapprocher de l'époque déjà de notre
de ce lieu de la construction et puis de
l'image peut
dire internationale
2 par exemple changer je pense au
pavillon chinois qui n'existe plus mais
qui a existé donc on joue un extrait
d'opéra nature en dot qui est inspiré de
ce thème le désert de red c'est un
jardin anglo-chinois créée à la fin du
xviiie siècle un microcosme qui
incarnent les civilisations via des
fabriques implantées sur place un lieu
emblématique spécialement choisis pour
l'occasion la garde républicaine du fait
de son histoire incarne justement ces
valeurs républicaines et il fallait
qu'elle puisse inscrire tout à la fois
ses racines musicales dans les racines
de l'histoire du peuple français qui y
trouvent naturellement leur assise au
sein du désert de red ce jardin des
lumières est donc issu de ce 18e
renaissant
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
[Musique]
on essaie déjà puisqu'on habite
chambourcy donc on sait pas la première
fois que nous venons ici mais c'est la
première fois que nous assistons à un
spectacle ici et le cadre franchement se
prête merveilleusement à la musique
écouter un concert comme celui là dans
un cadre pareil ça on voit beaucoup de
vibrations on ressent tous les
instruments près de 600 personnes ont
participé à ce concert en dehors des
sentiers battus
[Applaudissements]